welcome back to deepmind the podcast
i'm hannah fry a mathematician who's
been following the remarkable progress
in artificial intelligence in recent
years
in this series i'm talking to scientists
researchers and engineers about how
their latest work is changing our world
deepmind's big goal is solving
intelligence and over the next few
episodes we're going to be asking what
that could look like and just what
capabilities will be needed to create
artificial general intelligence
last time we heard why lots of work is
going into large language models that
give machines the ability to communicate
with humans but there are some people
here who believe that while
communication is an important tool in
its own right
its real value lies in facilitating
another skill that is integral to human
intelligence
the ability to cooperate
this is episode three
better together
communication acts as a booster for
cooperation if you want to cooperate you
first need to understand not only what
are your needs or desires but also what
are the other person's
needs or desires
that is the voice of torrey grepel
until recently he led the multi-agent
team at deepmind torrey and his
colleagues have defined cooperative ai
as helping humans and machines find ways
to improve their joint welfare and
building something capable of that goal
is he believes a crucial milestone in
the evolution of artificial intelligence
[Music]
the highest level of intelligence that
we know of is human
intelligence and humans are super
cooperators among all the animals humans
stand out as the species that is best at
cooperation you know that's how we've
built our civilization
and if we want to reach that level of
intelligence with machines
then we need to teach machines to
cooperate
admittedly whenever you read in the news
about conflicts and poverty and
discrimination around the world it
doesn't exactly seem as though humans
are paragons of cooperation
but it's also true that the endeavors of
which we humans are most proud the
biggest achievements of science art of
engineering or literature
are almost never down to a single person
the invention of the railway even the
creation of the covid19 vaccine
they all required great swells of people
pulling in the same direction
[Music]
is it almost like
intelligence at the level of a society
rather than just at the level of an
individual yes you could also take the
viewpoint that the group itself maybe a
family or maybe a whole country
is an intelligent entity because people
within it work together towards common
goals
this isn't just a theoretical idea that
we'll make a nice paper for an academic
conference
with self-driving cars we don't want to
be in a situation where you're trying to
merge into the left lane i'm trying to
merge into the right lane and we block
each other because neither of our cars
is willing to seed their own
self-interest from moments
[Music]
in the protection of the environment
individually each one of us thinks what
difference does it make if i don't save
on carbon emissions but if we all think
that way then collectively we will have
a problem
people talk about the possibility of
developing super intelligent machines
the analog would be a super cooperative
machine i mean it'd be quite handy to
have an entity that existed only to make
you happy yeah
we'll come on to all of that in a moment
but let's start with the question how do
you teach an agent to cooperate
part of the answer lies in the way
they're trained using a technique called
reinforcement learning
if you listen to series 1 of this
podcast you may well be familiar with
this approach to machine learning
already after all it's behind many of
deepmind's major breakthroughs in recent
years including alphago's victory over a
human player in the game of go
but it's worth having just a quick
refresher
joyner precup is head of deepmind's
montreal office and has spent decades
refining the technique of reinforcement
learning
the idea of reinforcement learning
originates really from psychology and
animal learning theory where people
thought that rewards are a good way for
animals to learn how to perform certain
tasks and of course skinner was one of
the pioneers in this line of work
b.f skinner was a famous american
psychologist known amongst other things
for his work using positive
reinforcement in pigeons
using a specially designed box that
would release a treat at his push of a
button skinner found that training
pigeons to perform a task like spinning
around anti-clockwise in a circle was
fantastically simple
you only needed to wait until the moment
the animal started behaving in the right
direction like turning to the left
before offering a treat
a hungry pigeon soon realizes that its
own actions are delivering treats and
the behavior is reinforced
the whole thing can take as little as 40
seconds
the advantage of using rewards is that
you can communicate the task to the
animal very easily and similarly if you
have an automated agent it may be able
to communicate the task to that agent
very easily
if we give the agent these rewards which
are numerical in our case
instead of giving ai's literal treats
the breadcrumbs that you'd fling to a
pigeon ais are rewarded with numbers
sounds a bit measly but think of it as
points in a computer game a plus one for
succeeding at a given task
and a minus one for failing
the agents are built only to maximize
the number of points they win and
optimizing for cooperation in this way
marks a subtle shift in the history of
ai
here's tori gratel again
at first agents were trained to solve
single agent tasks say to classify
images or to navigate through a maze
we then moved on to what we call
zero sum games
where one agent's gain is another
agent's loss
like for example in alphago and alpha
zero in these programs that play the
game of goal
and now the natural next step is to
consider
mixed motive scenarios where it's not
quite clear
how aligned agents are with one another
in their incentives but they still find
great cooperative solutions
cooperative behavior arises when you get
points not just for how well you do but
when the people around you also benefit
from your actions
in humans this is what psychologists
call our social value orientation
here's kevin mckee another research
scientist working on cooperative ai to
explain
if i'm at the coffee shop i'm there to
get my tea for the day and then right as
i get to the counter i think oh you know
actually i know hannah really likes
cappuccinos i do
i'm gonna grab an extra cappuccino and
bring it to you and there's no
expectation that you're going to get the
cappuccino from me next time but it's
still feasible that i buy the coffee
because i know that it'll bring you some
happiness
you can think about you know essentially
social value orientation maps pretty
well to random acts of kindness but
they're little things are they like
holding the door open for somebody or i
don't know giving up your seat on the
bus that kind of thing those small
things would be social value orientation
personally i think it goes a little bit
deeper than that anytime you get close
with someone you kind of redefine your
own self-interest in terms of the other
person's interest too
if i'm going to dinner with a partner or
a very close friend
and i decide to try a new dish if i was
by myself then maybe the only thing i'd
pay attention to is how much i liked
that dish
and then if i really liked it then okay
great next time i'll make sure to order
this again but actually if i'm going out
with my partner or a very close friend
or a family member let's say they like
really don't like it even the smell of
the fish dish that i just ordered it's
kind of driving them crazy then actually
i'll probably integrate that feedback
and decide actually the next time we go
out we won't even go to that restaurant
if it like really drove them crazy and
i'm describing reinforcement learning
i'm taking normally what would only be
my reward but in this case is the reward
of someone else and i'm using it to
modify
the likelihood that i take an action in
the future i have exactly that with
sardines my husband loves eating them
but i'm like i don't want to look at
that while i'm at a table but he takes
my feelings into account and doesn't
order them at social value rotation
okay so how do you instill that in
agents then so the environment provides
selfish reward already to each agent
when my husband eats a plate of
delicious sardines he gets a little
dopamine hit a plus one for his own
reward function
and so the way that we kind of build
social value orientation into our agents
is we also expose the reward that other
agents are receiving
minus one point for putting your
extremely delightful dinner partner off
her meal
but here's the question should they
really both be worth one point each how
much should you factor in the opinions
of others
the selfishness of agents is to a large
degree under our control toure
grapeville again so you can for example
design an
agent that when some other agent or
human comes into the room all they care
about is the well-being of that other
entity a purely altruistic almost
self-sacrificial agent might just pay
attention to the other agent's reward
it's almost like you got a little
selfishness style right it's like turn
it one way and they only live to serve
and turn it the other way and they're
like
fundamentally totally and completely
selfish
we're going to come back to that dial in
just a moment because i want to pick up
on something that the owl eared among
you might have already spotted
because there's one problem with basing
your reward function on another agent's
desires
you might not always be right about how
they're feeling it's not like we walk
around with the neon sign declaring how
happy or sad we are
[Music]
i mean i suppose we have our facial
expressions which are a bit of a clue
but you can lie right i could pretend i
thought the pasta dish was absolutely
delicious when really i thought it was
the most disgusting thing i've ever
tasted yeah we could end up in a
situation where you don't want to hurt
my feelings and so you say i love the
pasta dish and we end up going to that
restaurant several more times even
though it's not what either of us would
want so with agents then they're sort of
peeking at the answers for each other in
a lot of ways yeah
some people would think about that as
cheating and so a key challenge would be
how to build a system that can try to
infer those rewards for other agents and
then the con committed challenges that
kind of arise there would be around
deception this happens frequently in
negotiations right so you kind of don't
give away what your actual preferences
are so that you can try to nudge the
other person the other agent to doing
what you would like them to do so like
for example actually i don't mind the
pasta dish but i'm going to pretend to
you that i think it's disgusting because
the restaurant that i really want to go
to is much closer to my house and
knowing that you'll take into account my
feelings about the pasta dish actually i
can manipulate you into doing something
that you don't really want to do just
because i know how your reward function
works and i can deceive you about my
internal state exactly i'm just
describing my weekend with my husband
now
so with the power to code an algorithm
for altruism
surely he must be tempted to turn the
dial up to the maximum and see what
happens
but it turns out that pure altruism
might not be the most effective way for
whole groups of agents to cooperate
you and i let's say we're both perfectly
altruistic we are on opposite sides of a
door and trying to enter into the room
across from us if i just care about you
walking through the door first and you
just care about me walking through the
door first then we'll just sit there for
a while
perfect altruism gets you nowhere fast
and that can be quite a problem when it
comes to using these algorithms in
real-world scenarios
like self-driving cars
just think about an intersection where
one needs to yield
to the other
it's really not in anyone's interest
that the cars would just stand there and
not know what to do so somehow two cars
in that situation would have to
negotiate and figure out who goes first
and who goes second
[Music]
imagine the year is 2050.
you're in a busy metropolis and ai
driven cars fill the streets snaking
through traffic alongside pedestrians
bikes and other vehicles
if those cars are designed to be wholly
considerate of other road users it
simply must be the case that a
pedestrian stepping out in front of one
will cause it to stop
a selfless car would avoid collision at
all costs
but then what happens
the whole equilibrium of the road would
change
because suddenly
the pedestrians would feel empowered to
cross at any time and the very fact that
they are
forces the self-driving cars to react in
exactly the way that is expected of them
by those pedestrians and break every
single time
it's important to say here that the
researchers at deepmind aren't actually
working on selfless driverless cars for
the future but they are thinking very
carefully about this balance between
selfishness and altruism especially
because in the real world
most situations involve a delicate
combination of both
just think of a football team where each
player has an incentive to help their
team win the game
but also
wants to be the one to score the goal
or even arranging a meeting with a
colleague you both want the meeting to
take place but would like it to happen
at a time that suits you
researchers call these mixed motive
scenarios and they're the ones we
encounter most in everyday life
but there are other trickier situations
which encourage people to behave in more
selfish ways social dilemmas directly
incentivize the individual to behave in
a selfish way but if everyone behaves in
that selfish way
then the collective will suffer and you
can see examples of that everywhere in
human endeavor most crucially in the
protection of the environment
individually each one of us thinks what
difference does it make if i don't
save on carbon emissions but if we all
think that way
then collectively we will have a problem
there's that phrase in there it's just
one plastic bottle said seven billion
people
nice
this particular dilemma
is known as the tragedy of the commons
and it's a well-studied phenomenon in
economics
it arises when the incentives of the
individual are in conflict with what's
best for the group
of course we all want to protect the
environment but it's quite nice owning a
new car or having the heating on in
september and it's really hard to turn
down all of those things when nobody
else seems to be doing so
so as a result we all lose
torrey and his colleagues can run a
simplified idea of the same scenario in
a simulation a kind of ai petri dish to
see if there are ways to encourage more
cooperation
in the ai version of the tragedy of the
commons agents move around as little
dots in a grid world and receive a
positive reward every time they eat an
apple
these apples grow in little patches and
if you eat only some of the apples they
will regrow so if you harvest carefully
you can have apples and apples into
eternity
but once you destroy the whole patch of
apples nothing will ever grow there
anymore
if you were to put a single reward
maximizing agent into this world they
would soon realize that if they want to
ensure their future supply of apples
they will always have to leave one or
two in each patch
but what happens when two or more agents
live in this magical orchard
it's much harder now because they all
need to learn that it's good to leave a
few apples the best thing would be if
they could realize that it's forbidden
to take the last apple from a patch
and now the question is can we help them
discover these norms
and one way to do this is if you now
build walls within this environment so
that they all live in their little
territory
then they can act sustainably within
that territory again because that's like
the first case where there's just one
agent and of course we have a name for
that in society it's private property
as soon as it is a private piece of land
then the owner has an incentive to work
with it in a sustainable way
but the altruism dial isn't the only
lever
there are other ways to encourage
cooperation
having norms or rules imposed from above
being one way
but what if in the true spirit of
reinforcement learning you want agents
to work out how to cooperate by
themselves
this is an idea that tory and his
colleagues tested when they trained
seven agents to play a version of the
strategic board game diplomacy
i'm very scarred for my memories of
playing diplomacy because it almost
always ends in an argument i'm not
surprised i played it as a teenager with
friends or at least they were friends
when we started playing
the game of diplomacy is played on a
board painted with a big map of europe
set in the years leading up to the great
war each player takes on the role of one
of the great powers
france austria-hungary england russia
the aim is to move across the board form
alliances capture land and ultimately
beat your opponents
it is a good testbed for ai because it's
effectively a competition in your skill
to cooperate
the players need to walk that line
between being reliable alliance members
but because they can only win alone in
the end they also need to understand at
what point they need to leave those
alliances
[Music]
diplomacy is a notoriously challenging
game for ai to play
not only are there up to seven different
players who could perform an almost
infinite number of moves at every turn
but the game is a complex fusion of
cooperative and competitive dynamics
the diplomacy playing agents were
trained using a reinforcement learning
algorithm
each player assigns a value to each
situation in the game which is
essentially the probability of them
winning their goal is to make moves that
will increase this value and further
their objectives
remarkably tory and his colleagues
noticed that the seven players were
starting to cooperate with each other
without being explicitly taught to do so
we experimented first with a version of
the game where there is no communication
between the agents but even in that
setting we see that they support each
other's moves
to support a move in diplomacy means
pretty much what it might have meant in
early 20th century europe to lend some
troops and back up another player's
invasion say for instance someone has a
unit in berlin and wants to move into
munich
and they need the support of the
austrians
the attacker if you like needs to make
the move from berlin to munich
and they need to write that on their
little sheet of what they want to do and
the austrian party needs to write on
their sheet
my unit in vienna supports the move
from berlin to munich you see how much
coordination that requires these things
don't happen by chance that's a crazy
idea that they can recognize that
cooperating will give them the best
chance at long-term success and so even
if in that moment it doesn't directly
benefit
that particular agent they'll still
engage in it yes
as torrey mentioned so far the agents
playing diplomacy have been tackling a
simpler version of the game known as no
press where they are unable to
communicate with each other in order to
negotiate and make explicit agreements
this is mostly for technical reasons
because it turns out it's really hard
but researchers would like to add in
some form of communication in the future
and that communication probably in the
first step wouldn't be
full natural language it would probably
be simpler things like maybe just a
statement do you want to form an
alliance and the other agent could say
yes
but the ultimate goal of course would be
for these agents to play the game with
humans
once you start introducing slightly more
sophisticated forms of communication do
you expect these agents to become
devious
we
would expect them to do what's best for
them long term
and that might include deception they
might say one thing but then they would
behave in a different way and try to get
an advantage through that but maybe they
will also learn that in the long term
lying
will cost them their credibility
and if they lie too much other agents
will not pay attention to what they say
anymore or even punish them for lying
maybe the really good agents will
actually arrive at a strategy that would
at least most of the time tell the truth
that is i guess the idea with humans
that of course lying is possible but
there is pressure
to tell the truth because in the long
term it's a better strategy maybe just a
little lie every now and then
yeah
one of the reasons that researchers use
games is to understand how agents behave
in a safe environment
but the possibility of deception
does raise questions for how ai is
deployed in the real world
longer term
according to ethics researcher laura
weidinger who we heard from in the last
episode when ai reaches the real world
it should not be allowed to deceive
others
for example if you were to ask this ai
about the bank details of another person
it could just say i will not give you
this information i think more generally
i see real risks associated with ais
that can deceive it posits a risk for
human autonomy if the ai system deceives
me i could be manipulated to doing
things i wouldn't otherwise do of course
in fundamental research like in
particular games we may want to develop
something like deception this could give
us some important insights but in terms
of ai that is publicly released i
haven't yet seen an application where it
would be desirable for an ai to deceive
[Music]
so far in this episode we've mainly
explored how ai agents interact with
each other but as we heard at the start
those aren't the only partnerships worth
considering the future is also likely to
require quite a lot of cooperation
between ai and humans
in the real world it's rarely the case
that there's a task where an ai agent is
clearly better or if so it's a very
specialized task but often the team of
humans and artificial intelligence can
do it better together just think about a
radiologist we can now train ais that
are very good at classifying these
medical images but do you think that
ais will replace radiologists no they
make them better right because there are
other parts of their job to talk to the
patient to understand the bigger picture
of treatment
there's that famous quotation by curtis
langlotz a radiologist at stanford
ai won't replace radiologists he says
but radiologists who use ai will replace
radiologists who don't
but what's it actually like for humans
to cooperate with ai
well many of us already do this in our
daily lives when we talk to our smart
speaker or use facial recognition
systems to organize our photos
but what would happen if an ai and a
human
tried to cook a meal together well you
are about to find out
here's what happened when i donned my
chef's wipes and joined an ai in a
collaborative cooking game called
overcooked here's kevin mckee to explain
so two players partner together they
have to prepare dishes to serve in a
kitchen and you are fully sharing the
kitchen space
you first have to grab ingredients you
have to prepare them by let's say
chopping them up putting them in a pot
allowing them to cook and then serving
them on a dish
you might say this is relatively simple
but actually if you've ever cooked with
a family member or partner you know that
especially if you're under time pressure
it can be a challenge to kind of keep
cool tempers
and so maybe we won't necessarily be
cooking with our ai systems but
certainly we hope that we'll be
collaborating with them in close
proximity once we deploy them to the
real world
now i am never one to shy away from a
challenge so i fired up the engine and
let the game begin
[Music]
all right oh here i am that's my little
chef not being funny but my chef's got a
lot of swag it's pretty cool floppy hat
now it's telling me my chef is going to
be in a kitchen
it's quite a simple kitchen we're
talking maybe circa 1998
computer graphics you have to kind of
earn your way to the more advanced
kitchen
the game has a pixelated rectangular
kitchen with a stack of tomatoes on the
right a cooking pot in the middle and a
serving station on the left using
keyboard keys to navigate the objective
is to pick up the tomatoes put them in a
pot to start cooking and once they're
ready take the freshly made tomato soup
to the serving station
delicious
my reward a bonus of 10 cents for every
dish delivered
first i played a practice round by
myself to get the hang of it
right let's pick up a tomato oh gone too
far there we go right so i've got to go
get my soup lovely
and pop it on the serving station
great that was easy it seems like you've
been practicing this is pretty good
kevin then paired me up with two
different ai co-players
one of them looks exactly like me they
have long red hair and they're wearing
an orange suit so i'm looking forward to
going up against them or with them i
should say because we're a team
although i didn't know this until after
playing the first had been trained by
playing the game with a replica of
itself lots of times
this is a strategy which works well in
competitive games like go or chess but
it's not always conducive to cooperation
okay here we go let's play oh crikey
they're fast hang on chill out
sorry
hang on hang on hang on i'm trying to
get involved but they keep blocking me
excuse me
thank you
they're definitely a lot faster than i
am i mean we're doing well but i
wouldn't say i felt like i was
contributing fairly oh hang on i've got
the dish hold on
after 90 seconds of gameplay we managed
to deliver a total of four dishes to our
hungry customers not a bad score but i
can't say i played much of a role in
that
my second teammate was trained on a
range of partners with different playing
styles and was in theory the more
cooperative one oh you're much slower
aren't you there we go
you take your turn this partner in
comparison to the other one
is a lot slower but they're getting in
my way a lot less which i'm enjoying oh
hang on i've got too many tomatoes again
so actually i sort of think we're
working slightly better as a team this
time but maybe it's because we're just
both equally rubbish
so last time you got four dishes and
this time you got three well i mean
here's the thing it's asking me which
should i prefer the first part or the
second
the reality is even though we won
with the first partner i enjoyed the
experience more with the one who was
better matched to my speed levels is
that an unusual choice do you think
kevin no i i think that's the usual
choice you felt that your partner was
more responsive to your behavior and the
way that you were playing
the first one was as you're saying kind
of making a mad dash for for all of the
tomatoes
it's fair to say i got pretty into this
game after a while when i was finished
making tomato soup kevin told me more
about why i might have preferred playing
with the second partner
whereas the traditional approach to
training ai to play games like starcraft
and go has relied on getting them to
play endless games against themselves in
order to get as good as possible
for cooperative context the way that
your partner manages to maybe align
their behavior with yours probably
matters a lot and so we should be paying
more attention to it
because winning is not just about having
the best player on your team it's about
working together exactly
one thing you might have noticed by now
is that a lot of this cooperation work
is currently being done in simulation or
in gaming scenarios
in simulation it's absolutely safe
nothing gets broken tori grapel again we
have complete read out of what's
happening but then we want our agents
ultimately to work in the real world
and the real world will always differ
from simulation unless you believe we're
living in a simulation so how do we
overcome this simulation to reality gap
there are different general strategies
one of course is to make the simulation
as
accurate in reflecting reality as we can
another strategy is
to
create as much diversity in simulation
as we can so that the resulting agents
are not
changing their behavior depending on
details of the environment
do you think that an agent can
learn to be really cooperative in
simulation
the question of this true cooperation is
maybe a bit of a red herring
if the agents behave in a way that is
beneficial for their cooperation partner
and for themselves then i would call it
cooperation
i wouldn't then drill down on the
question if they meant it
it reminds me a little bit of my son
when i ask him to mow the lawn we always
joke and he says okay i'll do it and
then i say and you have to enjoy doing
it
he goes yeah that's ask too much isn't
it
but even if researchers like tori and
kevin are highly successful in getting
agents to cooperate in simulation
they will still need to bridge the
simulation to reality or sim to real gap
that toray alluded to
after all the real world is messy full
of unpredictable actors and unforeseen
circumstances
and there are researchers who believe
that it's only by having embodied ai in
the real world that true artificial
general intelligence can be achieved
in the next episode we're going to be
paying a visit to one of my favorite
places the deepmind robotics lab
looks like it's a drunk robot so it's
trying to walk backwards but it's sort
of um
it's just given up
it's given up and it's really full
that's next time on the deepmind podcast
presented by me hannah fry and produced
by dan hardoon at whistledown
productions
special thanks to goodkill music who
produced the catchy tune for the
overcooked game which we used in this
episode
if you've been enjoying this series
please do leave us a rating or review if
you can goodbye
[Music]